The deity of Christ removed.
Islam makes Christ the man. I'm going to
give a whole lecture on this so I'm not
going to talk on this issue. Matthew
6:22, God forbid, Lord, far be it from
thee, Lords. Slight difference. We won't
go into the details. Titus 2:13,
awaiting our blessed hope, the RSV, the
appearance of the glory of our great God
and Savior Jesus Christ. The ASV,
looking for the blessed hope and the
appearance of the glory of the great God
and Savior Jesus Christ. And the King
James says, looking for the blessed hope
and the glorious appearing of the great
God and our savior Jesus Christ. Here
Jesus is God. Here he has only the glory
that God gives him. So he is subordinate
to God in the RSV and the ASV. The
Isaiah
7:14, listen to this change. Therefore,
the Lord himself will give you a sign.
Behold, a young woman will shall
conceive and bear a son, and you shall
call his name Emmanuel.
Please explain to me how a young woman
conceiving a child can be a sign for
anyone.
Who could qualify?
everyone. So, it's not a sign at all.
It's pathetic.
But the King James version says,
"Therefore, the Lord himself will give
you a sign. Behold, a virgin shall
conceive and bear a son and shall call
his name Emanuel." Now, that's a sign.
That's strange. That's something
special. Jewish scholars amongst the RSV
translators, so they obviously wanted
this change. Rabbi Balffor Brickner
writes the following. I am delighted to
know that at least this great error of
translation has been finally corrected
and that at least some elements of the
Christian world no longer officially
maintain that Isaiah 7:14 is a
prediction that Jesus was to be born of
the Virgin Mary. Okay, so they've just
removed his virgin birth.
RSV, your divine throne endures forever.
Thy throne, oh God, is forever. The name
of God is here reduced to the adjective
divine. But when this text is quoted in
Hebrews 1:8,
it is made to apply to the son. So we
better change it here in Psalms, or else
Jesus might be God. You see, because
Hebrews 1 vers8 says, "But unto the son
he says, thy throne, oh God, is forever
and ever." But of the Son, he says, "Thy
throne, oh God, is forever and ever."
You see, even the RSV is the same there
as the King James. So, where did they
change it? They changed it in the Psalms
so that Jesus wouldn't have it applied
to him. Now, this gets pretty serious.
Proverbs chapter 8 verse 22. RSV, the
Lord created me at the beginning of his
work. What is Jesus now? He's a created
being. The NIV, the Lord brought me
forth as the first of his works. What is
he in the NIV? He's a created being. The
Lord possessed me in the beginning. He
was part of God in the beginning. So in
the King James, he's God. Here he is a
created being.
Daniel 3:2
calls him son of the gods. Son of gods.
Son of the gods. King James. Son of God.
Big difference.
Now again Micah 5:2 RSV from you shall
come forth for me one who is to bear
ruler in in whose origin is from old
from ancient days whose going forth have
been from old from everlasting so here
he has an origin he's created and there
he has no creator Matthew 1 verse 25
he's no longer the firstborn son he's
just you will have a
King James, he's the firstborn son. So,
she was a virgin. But if they removed
the virgin bit, they better remove it
here, too. So, they removed it in the
RSV. And it go gets even worse in the
footnote. They say that Joseph is the
father of Jesus.
The King James, Joseph, the husband of
Mary, of whom was born Jesus, who is
called Christ. See, so here he is
miraculously born. And there he has an
earthly father.
And if we go to the King James, Joseph
and his mother marveled at those things
which were spoken of him. The due his
father and mother were wondering at
those things. So what happens now? Jesus
no longer has a miraculous birth. And uh
you'll find the same in the NIV. The
child's father and mother marveled at
what was said. Matthew 13:51.
Have you understood all these things?
Jesus asked. Yes, they replied. RSV says
the same thing. Yes. The King James
says, "Yay, Lord." So, they recognize
him as God. Curios.
Oh, by the way, that's been removed
many, many times. Hundreds of times in
the NIV. Everywhere where it says Jesus
is Lord, that's gone in the NIV.
This one's very interesting. Matthew
19:16-1 17. teacher, what good deed must
I do to have eternal life? And he said
to him, why do you ask me about what is
good? One there is who is good. Good
master,
there's a difference. What good thing
shall I do that I may have eternal life?
And he said unto him, why callst thou me
good? You see the difference? There is
none good but one that is God. Now,
what's the difference here? This is a
fascinating text. You see in the RSV
goodness is not applied to the person in
the King James he is calling Jesus good
master and Jesus recognizes something in
him and he says to him why do you call
me good master for surely you know that
there is one that is good and that is
God.
So what is he saying? You have
recognized something. What have you
recognized?
you have recognized that I am God.
That's what he says to him. So that's
gone. That's changed. So that Jesus is
not recognized by this young man as God.
We're going to get deeper into this.
Matthew 27:35.
Everywhere, just about everywhere in the
New Translations, where the Bible says,
"That it might be fulfilled which was
spoken by the prophet, they parted my
garments among them, and upon my vesture
did they cast lots." Everywhere where
the Bible says that, the modern
translations have removed it. Why do you
think they have removed it in the modern
translations?
I'll tell you why. because it proves
that Jesus is the fulfillment of
prophecy. And so they've taken it away
so that he does not fulfill prophecy
everywhere.
Matthew 2:15, out of Egypt I have called
my son. Out of Egypt did I call my son.
Hosea is now not a fulfillment of
prophecy because those are the exact
words used in Hosea applied in the New
Testament. They changed them so that
Hosea is not a fulfillment of that
prophecy anymore. Mark 15:3.
And he answered nothing. It says, "And
the chief priest accused him of many
things." The King James says, "But he
answered nothing." Why is that left away
in the RSV and the NIV and the ASV? I'll
tell you why. Because it's a fulfillment
of prophecy. It's a fulfillment of
prophecy. Take it away. Jesus must not
fulfill the prophecy. He's no better
than any one of us. And the scripture
was fulfilled which says that he was
numbered with the transgressors. RSV
gone. Mark 15:28.
1 John 4:3.
And every spirit that confessth not that
Jesus Christ is come in the flesh. This
is a central doctrine.
Is not of God. It's the spirit of
Antichrist.
RSV. And every spirit which does not
confess Jesus is not of God. Oops. the
NIV. Every spirit that does not
acknowledge Jesus is not from God. Well,
if they leave it out, then I must assume
that the NIV and the RSV was written by
the spirit of Antichrist, right? Or not.
Yes or no?
Well, what do you say? Must be because
it's not there. So, they're denying it.
His post-resurrection appearance in the
RSV, the original one gone.
Matthew 6:13, King James. And lead us
not into temptation, but deliver us from
evil. For thine is the kingdom and the
power and the glory forever and ever.
Amen. Gone. Why' they leave it out? In
the DA, in the RSV, in the NIV, for
thine is the kingdom and the power and
the glory gone because Jesus must no
longer be exalted. Luke 11:2,
Father, hallowed be your name. This is
interesting. Your kingdom come. etc. He
said to them, "When you pray, say,
"Father, hallowed be your name." NIV,
King James. And he said to them, "When
you pray, our Father, which art in
heaven, hallowed be thy name. Thy
kingdom come, thy will be done on earth
as it is in heaven." Now, why remove all
those verses?
You see here in the RSV and the NIV, you
can pray to whom?
You can have the pope as father. You can
have the pope. But here you can't
because our father who art in heaven
cannot be the pope. So let's take those
verses out. Luke 11:28.
And he said unto them, when you pray,
the same story. You'll see all those
texts, the RSV and the NIV, they're all
taken out.
Uh post-resurrection appearance omitted.
Luke 24:40 RSV missing. King James. And
when he had thus spoken, he showed them
his hands and his feet. So they took out
Mark. So they take it out in Luke as
well. What about his miraculous
ascension? And he was carried up into
heaven and they worshiped him. Gone.
Gone. While they blessed him, he
departed from them, and they returned to
Jerusalem with great joy. It's just
gone. Leave it up. John 3:13.
Again, no one has ascended into heaven,
but he who descended from heaven, the
son of man, which is in heaven. What
does that make Jesus? It makes him God
who is now in heaven. Just taken out.
Now notice this one. John 6:33.
For the bread of God is that which comes
down from heaven.
And the bread of God is he which comes
down from heaven. There it's bread.
And there it's a person. Big difference.
Jesus is systematically removed in the
modern translations.
Truly, truly I say unto you, he who
believes has eternal life. Who believes
what? That frogs are gods. And there are
religions that believe that by the way
today alive and living in a well in
Japan for example. Who believes what?
Mother Terza says whatever you believe
God is, that you must accept. That's
good enough. No, no, no. The King James
says, "Verily, verily, I say unto you,
he that believeth on me has eternal
life." Gone. Two little words. They make
a big, big difference. John 16:16, RSV.
A little while and you will see me no
more. Again, a little while and you will
see me.
I laugh about this text. You know what
this text means? Jesus was playing
hideand seek.
He was peeping behind a tree. He was
standing there behind a tree and he
says, "Now you see me. Now you don't.
Now you see me. Now you don't." It's
pathetic. God wouldn't put a stupid text
like that in the Bible. The NIV. Well,
it's just as stupid. In a little while,
you will see me no more, and then after
a little while, you will see me. Well,
I'm going to stand behind a tree. That's
what I'm going to do.
The King James says, "A little while and
you shall see me. And again, a little
while and you shall you shall not see
me." or a little while, you shall not
see me. And again, a little while, and
you shall see me because I go to the
Father. That makes sense.
Which one do you think God spoke? You
tell me. Come on. Obviously, this one.
This is pathetic. This is absolutely
pathetic.
I get angry sometimes. I must calm down.
John 16:23.
If you ask anything of the father, he
will give it to you in my name. Whatever
you shall ask the father in my name, he
will give it to you. There's a huge
difference between that text. You just
think about it here. The whole character
of God and his truth is implied here.
Anything goes.
Acts 2:30. being therefore a prophet and
knowing that God had sworn with an oath
to him that he would set one of his
descendants upon the throne here oath to
him that of the fruit of his loins
according to the flesh
he would raise up Christ to sit on his
throne. Why do you think the of his
flesh is out? Why do you think so?
Because they deny the doctrine of the
physical coming of God in the flesh. He
who denies it is what? Antichrist.
So again, we have the spirit of
Antichrist in the RSV.
Acts 8 verse 36 and 37. Well, this is a
sad one. The whole atonement gone. If
thou believest with all thine heart,
thou mayest. And he answered and said, I
believe that Jesus Christ is the son of
God. The whole verse, verse 37, take it
out. Not Jesus saves you. You save
yourself. That's how you get saved. You
save yourself.
Acts 9 29 he talked and debated with the
Greek and Jews but they tried to kill
him. Interesting. King James he spoke
boldly in the name of the Lord Jesus and
disputed against the Grecians but they
went about to slay him. You see what
makes the difference? Jesus makes the
difference. If you want an ecumenical
Bible well here's argument and debate
but here the debate is about Jesus
Christ. He makes the difference. Acts
22:16
and wash away your sins calling on his
name. NIV and wash your sins away
calling on his name. And wash away the
sins calling on the name of the Lord.
Just one of those where they've removed
him. The gospel concerning his son, his
son Jesus Christ our Lord. Here it could
be his son Lucifer.
Here it is the son Jesus Christ our
Lord. Big difference. Romans 9:5
according to the flesh is the Christ God
who is overall as concerning the flesh
Christ came who is overall here Jesus is
higher than everyone else they're
different
we shall all stand before the judgment
seat of God says the RSV in Romans 14:10
but the King James says we shall all
stand before the judgment seat of Christ
that makes Christ God And not only that,
it exalts Jesus as the judge. But here
they have removed this privilege from
Jesus and made it sort of general. 1
Corinthians 15:47.
The first man was from the earth, the
man of dust. The second man is from
heaven. The first man is of the earth,
earthly. The second man is the Lord from
heaven. Big difference.
Now 1 Timothy 3:16, God great indeed. we
confess is the mystery of our religion.
He was manifested in the flesh. Who was
manifested in the flesh? Hello. Would
you care to look at me? I am manifested
in the flesh. Can you see me? I'm flesh
and bones. It's no big deal. But here,
and without controversy, great is the
mystery of godliness. God was manifest
in the flesh. There's a difference. You
see how they systematically
reduce Jesus and how they take him out
of the gospels? It's a shame. It's a
crying shame. And this one is the
bomber. Do you know how much debate
there is in the world today about the
Trinity? And they say trinity is not
doctrine of the Bible. It has to be
removed. And they're right. You cannot
prove it in the NIV and you cannot prove
it in the RSV. You cannot prove the
Trinity. And they say it's Roman
Catholic doctrine. No, hang on a second.
Roman Catholic doctrine is father,
mother, child on the esoteric inner
circle. For the goyam, it's father, son,
and holy spirit. But the esoteric
doctrine of Roman Catholicism, I'll
prove this in a later lecture, is
father, mother, child. But it is a copy
of the heavenly. And here you can see
it. 1 John 5:7, for there are three that
testify, nothing said. King James, for
there are three that bear record in
heaven, the Father, the Word, and the
Holy Ghost, and these three are one.
That makes Jesus God and part of the
triune Godhead. This text shows that
there are three powers in heaven, the
Father, the Son, and the Holy Spirit.
And all three are in the fullest sense
God. That's what the text says. Out away
with it in the modern translations.
God re restth upon you and their part is
evil spoken of by on your part. He is
glorified. Gone. The glorification of
Jesus removed from 1 Peter 4:14.
Revelation 1. What do they remove? I am
the alpha and the omega. the first and
the last gone. His eternal godhood
removed. Revelation 5:14. And the four
four beasts said, "Amen." And the four
and 20 elders fell down and worshiped
him that liveth forever and ever. He's
eternal godhood. He is eternal. Gone out
of the RSV, gone out of the NIV.
Well, Matthew 4:4, but he answered and
said, "It is written, man shall not live
by bread alone, but by every word that
proceedth out of the mouth of God." How
must you know what God said if they've
confused it to such an extent? And just
based on simple logic, which one do you
think is the most probable correct text?
The one is rendered in the King James or
the one as rendered in the other
versions? Which ones do you say? What do
you say? It can only be the King James
because the others, some of the verses
are so pathetic,
that's the only word for them. So
pathetic, it's a nice word, rolls of the
tongue, that I make no sense whatsoever.
Now, here's an interesting story. This
is St. Katherine's protector at Mount
Si.
Now, what was given at Mount Si? What
did God give to Moses at Mount Si?
>> He gave the law. He gave the whole Bible
to him. the pentat the first five books
he received them directly from God and
he wrote them down in a book and it's
called the law of Moses and this camel
has nothing to do with it he's just
there to look cute
now here is Mount Si they say that the
tablets of stone were heuned from this
very rock that's just uh traditional
delivery up we go to Mount Si here it is
where God spoke if this is the right
place. We're not really sure, but
nevertheless, where God spoke in great
majesty and gave the law on top there's
a little Coptic church and uh it's tough
climbing up there. My feet were sore.
And uh let's go down and go and then we
find something else. Elijah's basin.
There's the sign. Mount Si, Elijah's
basin down there. And tradition says
this is where Elijah came when he ran
away from Jezebel. Now think about this
here at Sinai. God sends out his words.
It's a great thought.
Elijah ran to this place and this is
where he hid from Jezebel. Why did he
run from Jezebel? What had he done that
he should run from Jezebel? I'll tell
you what he' done.
He'd had a confrontation with the
priests of Baal,
a mighty confrontation between truth and
error. And after the confrontation, God
took him back all the way to Sinai.
That's where the word came from. That's
what made the confrontation possible.
Now what stands on Mount Carmel today?
A huge Bahigh temple
which preaches that all religions are
the same. There's no difference between
the various religions. So it seems as if
in the last days
a new doctrine has come in. No
difference between religions. But Elijah
preached there is a difference and there
is a judgment. And he comes back to the
law here si today. No, on mount carmile
there is a bahigh temple which says all
religions are exactly the same.
And something else from Sinai the word
of God went into the worlds.
And from Sinai today something else goes
into the world. There's a monastery.
It's St. Katherine's monastery. That's
where the syniticus text was found. That
is the text on which all the corruptions
which we've just read in the Bible are
based. So here from Sinai a new word is
sent out into the worlds.
A corrupt word. So Carmel is corrupted.
There is no difference. God is not a God
that says come out be separate. make a
difference between them and those that
worship the living God is the one
message sent into the world today. And
the other one is here is the ecumenical
word for you. We are all one. We are
sitting in one pot. The devil hates
Carmel. The devil hates the law of God.
And he is counteracting it right here.
He has taken that which God used and
made it his own. He is sneaky. Wouldn't
you agree? I think he's very sneaky. 1
Kings 18:21. And Elijah came unto all
the people and said, "How long halt ye
between two opinions.
If the Lord be God, follow him. But if
Bal, then follow him, and the people
answered him, not a word." They would
have preferred to worship both. Then we
would have had peace and quiet.
Today, they want to do the same thing.
They want to worship both.
Now I would like to invite three people,
three volunteers,
one with an NIV,
one with a Revised Standard Version if
you have one with you, and one with a
King James just to come up to the front
and we'll do a little experiment. Just a
quick one, just for fun. Let's do it.
This is great.
Now, I don't know how quickly we're
going to find these texts, but let's
just look up a few. Will you look up
Matthew chapter 17 verse 21?
Matthew chapter 17 verse 21.
>> Shall I hold it for you? I'll hold it
for you.
>> Verse 21.
>> Yes.
>> Will you read it to me out of the King
James?
>> How this kind of goeth not out but by
prayer and fasting?
>> This one goeth not out but by prayer and
fasting. What does the NIV say?
>> I can't see 21. Is it 20?
>> Oh, yeah.
>> You replied because you have
>> That's 20. No, I want only verse 21,
please.
>> Okay.
Why doesn't it say 21 here?
>> Oh. Oh, it doesn't say 21. What does
What does the RSV say?
>> It doesn't say either.
>> Oh, the RSV doesn't say it either. Let's
go to Matthew 18:1.
>> 18 vers
>> 18 vers 11. What does the King James
say?
>> For the Son of Man has come to save that
which was lost.
>> Oh, that's a potent verse. How many
sermons have been preached on that word?
What does the NIV say?
>> It It says verse 10 and verse 12. There
is no verse 11.
>> There is no verse.
>> Oh, okay. What does the RSV say?
>> Same.
>> You can't find it in there. Oh, that's
rather sad. What about Matthew 23:14?
Could you read that for me, please?
Woe unto you scribes and Pharisees,
hypocrites, for ye devour widows houses,
and for a
pretense make long prayer. Therefore, ye
shall receive the greater damnation.
>> Wow. The clergy that is so exalted now
gets
one knock. What does yours say?
>> Verse 14. For many are invited, but few
are chosen.
>> Is that Matthew 23:14?
>> That's Yeah. 22:14.
>> No, 23:14.
>> 234. Sorry.
No, 14. There's 13 and 15.
>> Oh, the surely you know they must be so
exalted Jesus made a mistake with that
verse. Let's just take it out. What does
yours say?
>> Nothing.
>> Oh, it doesn't have it either. What
about Mark 7:16?
>> Mark 7:16.
You can all page in your Bibles and
verify this for yourselves.
>> 716.
>> 7:16.
>> If any man have ears to hear, let him
hear.
>> Verse 14 and 15, but no verse 16.
>> No verse 16.
>> No, not either.
>> It's important to listen to the word of
God. No, let's take that out. What about
Mark 9:44?
>> Mark 94
>> 9:44
>> where their worm dieth not and the fire
is not quenched.
>> There's a verse 43 and a verse 45, but
no verse 44.
>> No verse 44.
>> No, I hear
>> no verse 44. That's a interesting text.
We can deal with it in a later lecture.
What's about verse 46?
>> Verse what?
>> 946.
>> for where the worm died and the fire is
not.
>> Yeah, it's left out both times, right?
>> There's a verse 45 and a verse 47, but
no verse 46.
>> What about Mark 11:26?
Mark 11:26.
But if you do not forgive, neither will
your father which is in heaven forgive
your trespasses.
>> Well, there's a verse 25 and a verse 27,
but no verse 26.
>> You know, we could go on like this for a
long long time. None of those verses
will be there. So, let's go to some
interesting verses that are there. Let's
go to Acts 9 verse 5-6.
Acts chapter 9 verse 5-6.
>> And he said, "Who art thou, Lord?" And
the Lord said, "I am Jesus, whom thou
persecutest. It is hard for thee to kick
against the pricks."
>> Acts 9:5 and6.
Who are you, Lord? Saul asked. I am
Jesus whom you have persecuted, he
replied. Now get up and go into the city
and you will be told what you must do.
>> Okay. And then the other way,
>> who are you, Lord? And he said, who are
you, Lord? And he said, I am Jesus whom
you are persecuting. But rise and enter
the city, and you will be told what you
are to do.
>> So what has been left out?
the whole P part where there is
opposition and battling against two
options.
So in an ecumenical Bible you don't want
division, you want unity. So all these
division texts where you make a
decision, they're gone in the new ones.
Go to Romans chapter 8 verse one.
Romans chapter 8 verse one.
There is therefore now no condemnation
to them which are in Christ Jesus, who
walk not after the flesh, but after the
spirit.
>> Therefore, there is now no condemnation
for those who are in Christ Jesus.
That's all.
>> Where's the last bit?
>> Not there.
>> Oh, so if you have Jesus, you are saved.
No change necessary in your life. What
about the RSV?
>> There is therefore now no condemnation
for those who are in Christ Jesus.
>> No change need needed who walk not after
the flesh. Does that imply a change and
a conversion? Yes or no?
>> Absolutely. Gone. Because we want to
have one big unity. What about these are
all texts that we didn't even deal with
in this lecture and we could carry on
and on and on and on and on with them.
What about 1 Timothy 3:16? Let's just
look at that one.
>> Timothy 1
>> Timothy
>> 1 Timothy 3 verse 16.
And without controversy, great is the
mystery of godliness. God was manifested
in the flesh, justified in the spirit,
seen of angels, preached onto the
Gentiles, believed on in the world,
received up into glory.
>> Is it verse 316?
>> Yes.
>> 316.
>> It's not in there.
There it is.
>> Oh,
>> there's a little bit of it there.
>> The pillar and foundation of the truth.
Beyond all question, the mystery of
godliness is great.
He appeared in a body, was vindicated by
the spirit, was seen by angels, was
preached among the nations, was believed
on in the world, was taken up in glory.
And you have the same. He was right.
He was
>> Yes. It says, "Great indeed we confess
is the mystery of our religion.
He was manifested in the flesh,
vindicated in the spirit, seen by
angels, preached among the nations,
believed on in the world, taken up in
glory.
>> And if you take that home with you
tonight, then that is the crux of the
matter."
The King James version says
God was manifest in the flesh. Jesus
Christ is God. Jesus Christ is the only
one who can save you. Jesus Christ is
the only one whereby you can be saved
because he's the only one who made you
and therefore he's the only one who can
redeem you. He's the only one who can
open the seals of the scroll. No one
else, no created being, no angel, only
Jesus Christ. And if you want to prove
any of the doctrines of the Bible, you
better have a King James or any other
Bible that existed before these early
1900s.
You can take the Russian Bible. You can
take the Serbian Bible. You can take the
old Croatian Bible. You can take the
Luther 1912 Bible. Just don't take the
1984. You will find a tremendous change.
You can take any old Bible in the world
except the dua of course and the Vulgate
and you will find all the doctrines
necessary for understanding salvation in
Christ Jesus. But any new translation
treat with suspicion
in off in the Africans in my own country
the old Africans Bible tremendous
exactly the same as the King James the
new like the NIV in Germany if you have
an Elba Bible it's exactly like the NIV
you can find none of the doctrines in it
anymore you will have to get a Luther
1912 or a Schlaa Bible in order to find
the truth and we could go right around
the world. The Armenian Bible.
Fantastic. Fantastic. They're now
writing a new Bible version in Croatia
for the Serbian language. Forget it. It
is a corruption. It's based on Westcot
and Hort's translations.
So, I hope tonight you have found that
what you read
makes a difference. Now, let me tell
you, I personally like the New King
James Bible. I like it. But there are
huge numbers of mistakes in it.
Horrendous mistakes in it. Some that
really destroy some pivotal doctrines.
But I quite enjoy it because I put it in
because I use the King James to verify
it and I cross it out to where it's
wrong and my whole Bible is crossed out
and redone and whatever. I find that
fun. It keeps my mind going and active
and uh so if you want to use another
translation just be aware of these
issues
and then verify your studies with one
that you can trust and the textus
recepticus has come down through the
stream of time. It has been the one that
led the to to the reformation. It has
been the one that people have stood and
died for and it is the one that will
make a difference at the end. You
believe me?
Heat.
Heat. Heat.